here is what this little [__] had to
say I'm not as it's not as though the
cover up of the radical Muslim Israel
right now is a safe haven for pedophiles
okay I don't care where you stand on any
political issue if you're a Democrat
Republican we should all be
outraged brothers and sisters it is the
winter season in the UK today in my
house my boiler block and the house was
freezing cold my kids are wearing
jackets I'm trying to find heating and
as a father I'm trying to make sure my
kids my wife are warm imagine the people
around the world I'm working with one
say 100% donation policy charity who are
helping Syria Lebanon and Afghanistan
people who are freezing to death intense
brothers and sisters donate whatever you
can because today's experience with me
showed me Subhan Allah how vulnerable we
are and just made me remember those
people who are in need whatever you
donate guys even if it is1 help those
people in those
countries brothers and sisters and dear
friends as you guys know this whole
thing of um grooming gangs and this
whole Fiasco that's been happening for
the past 13 years uh being um taken
advantage of by likes of Tommy Robinson
who's been funded by the Zionist once
again with Elon musk's help which as you
guys know he changed his Stone when he
went to Israel for some odat reasons
he's now promoting Tommy Robinson it's
not a coincidence guys it's orchestrated
very perfectly and clearly uh as you
know the genocide that's going on in
Gaza this is a maneuver for them to take
the attention from that and that's
exactly what we saw by this intellectual
[__] who who is um actually afraid I
mean we've seen him gulping at the name
of Muhammad hijab he's terrified he's
refused um debates of initiate
performance so here's what he said on
Twitter and Muhammad hijab obviously
responded to him but here it goes and
then we're going to talk about Candace
Owens and we are going to get deeper
because we're about to uh do a backflip
or we're going to be flipping this whole
thing on their head why because if we
look closer guys um there was articles
on CBS in the Jerusalem Post of tens of
thousands of Israeli Peters fouls
grooming gangs whatever you want to call
um who Israeli individuals returning
back to Israel and running away from the
law and getting a step in the hand in
Israel we're going to talk about in a
minute and Candace Owens brings evidence
to this here is what this little [__]
had to say I'm not as it's not as though
the cover up of the radical Muslim rape
gangs in Britain was a mystery
journalists openly admitted to knowing
about it for years and failing to report
it because they were afraid it might
help the British national party and
English Defense League mammed responded
it is interesting you outline their
religion rather than their ethnic
background let me tell let me ask you
what have you have what have you had to
say about the Lev Taho Jewish grooming
gangs that operate in
Galo two weeks ago should we link them
with Judaism a very valid question and
talking about this let's go to Candace
Owen's video clip where she talks about
this phenomen that is happening and not
only that in Cyprus a girl a white
British girl was gang graped by seven
Israeli IDF soldiers did you hear about
that did Tommy Robinson talk about that
or Paul Golding did any of the farat
talk about it is Elon mus talking about
it no they are not because it's not that
they care about the victim they rather
care who is the perpetrator here's what
K had to say let's watch this insh and
make some conclusions and look at the
study of tens of thousands of pedophile
grooming gangs who are running to Israel
for Safe Haven under the right to return
law further to that first and foremost
is the the fact that Israel as an
example for people that feel this pull
to defend this country on the basis of
the fact that you're Jewish Israel right
now is a safe haven for pedophiles okay
I don't care where you stand on any
political issue if you're a Democrat
Republican we should all be outraged
that we are sending our dollars overseas
to a country that is protecting
pedophiles so we're talking about men
like Leo Frank who rape little girls
know that they can go if they're Jewish
they can go to Israel and they'll be
provided a safe haven I'm going to show
you two articles that are going to
substantiate that claim because people
will say what are you talking no it's
1,00% true here is an article CBS News
how Jewish American pedophiles hide from
Justice in Israel here's another article
uh the Jerusalem Post tens of thousands
of pedophiles operate in Israel every
year has approved the extradition of sex
crime suspect Mala leer to Australia
leer was the former principal of an
ultra Orthodox Australian day school and
is wanted on 74 sexual assault charges
including rape at the institution CBS
This Morning we have a followup on a CBS
News investigation from last year it's a
very disturbing issue child abuse
suspects in this country who fled to
Israel now one of those suspects his
name is Gershon Craner was returned to
New York City just yesterday to face the
charges after more than a decade in
Israel he is accused of molesting two
female relatives one of them was just 6
years old at the time a long wait for
Justice at least it took nearly two
decades but today a woman who was raped
as a teenager finally got to face the
man who police police say attacked her
his name is moist joural investigators
say the former Dormont business owner
assaulted her in 2004 at a tanning salon
then he took off for Israel it wasn't
until 2019 the investigators were able
to bring him back to face charges so in
the not show guys you can see very
clearly that we're about to like I said
before going to flip this on this head
because when we if we ever confront like
which I have Tommy Robinson but if I
ever come to face with with him again or
anyone for the far and I challenge them
openly how about that in Speakers Corner
wherever you want inshallah anytime to
come and debate this issue because I
know you guys are sick in the head you
want to make this a Muslim Pakistani SL
Indian Asian whatever issue it is
because you are sick in the head you are
more focused not the you do not care
about who is the victim you rather care
about the perpetrator your focus is on
the perpetrator no it shouldn't be an
Asian doing this issue we don't mind if
it's our own if it's our own it's fine
but if it's an Asian no so here is the
Articles let's read the articles in this
is from the the New Jerusalem Post okay
it says in July alone there were 22
cases of pedophilia recorded in Israel
brought to to the attention of the media
tens of thousands of pedopiles operate
every year in Israel leading to about
100,000 victims annually now this is a
report not like this [__] uh in the
commment Lord this Lord whatever he is
this filippin [__] he's saying 250,000
girls where did you get this number from
where' you get this number from number
one number two the mats of Association
an organization that actively keeps
track of reports on pil in VAR various
media and centralizes the data monthly
states that in July alone cases of
pedophilia were reported in Israel and
brought to the attention of the media
the ma the vast majority go unreported
in Israel tens of thousands of pedopiles
operate on a daily basis without any
problem said eliran mki head of the
mazov association they are not deterred
by the police and certainly not deterred
by the contemptuous rulings that come
from the hands of judges in various
courts he added uh citing an incident
which one particular pedophile was let
off by the court without punishment
despite pres of thousands of pedophilic
items found on his computer as the cour
stated that it would harm his career
harm his career so do you see the same
phenomena happening here they are
averting that why because it would harm
is Korea the court does not count the
number of victims and shows
disproportionately favorable treatment
of the perpetrators according to Mali
the association gathers reports from the
media in order to form statistics as no
public sex offenders registry in Israel
currently exists they don't even have
one okay this is um one um in June in
June at least 22 instances of pedifile
activities were reported in the media
including a 26y old man committed in in
indecent acts on two brothers age six
and eight in a public park in BBA a
40-year-old man who committed indecent
acts on his girlfriend's 11year old
daughter daughter while they were still
living together before he was sentenced
to 6 years in prison so brothers and
sisters as you can see some of them are
pet f in America running for to save
Haven in Israel under the right of
return and one individual who committed
these acts got just two years in prison
and was let go brothers and sisters the
point we're trying to make is the
following as Muslims ourself there is no
correlation or connection to the acts of
any groomer for that matter and not only
that all of the fars every single one of
them who are against Islam or Muslims or
whatever for this matter would love and
die for the law because your law says
what you tap them in the hand give them
a couple of years play Xbox watch TV in
prison not the Sharia the Sharia will
deal severely with them and all of you
guys will be Pro Sharia all of you guys
will say we want the Sharia to be
implemented on them you will love the
Sharia you will die for the Sharia when
it comes to this incident because there
is no kind of correlation or causation
between these vile individuals who are
taking these girls and doing whatever
for that matter and brothers and sisters
we hate these V individuals we hate the
person who's doing the action this evil
action to whoever is done we don't care
if it's a Muslim girl or a white girl or
a brown girl or a green we don't care
it's the action that should be severely
dealt with not the perpetrator we don't
come and say oh was it one of our own
that done was it a Muslim that done oh
it's fine oh if it's a white man oh no
it cannot be a white man the action is
evil whoever is done by and that's why
it makes a sick to our stomach to see
that individuals who are taking
advantage of this for their own purpose
Pur is an own agenda and making it seem
like Toby Robinson is a some kind of a
you know political prisoner no he's not
he's a criminal yes because of contempt
of court he's in jail it's as simple as
that this nonsense that the people are
trying to shut him down is absolutely
garbage and Candace Owens is bringing
light to this and we are going to be
tackling this headon with anyone that
believes they have some ground to stand
on that Islam has some kind of
connection correlation causation
whatever you want to call it with these
vile individuals who have done these
acts whoever they are white black green
blue I don't care I dare you so come and
challenge us on this matter inshallah
that's all I have to say brother and
sisters may Allah bless and protect you
guys do not forget to check out the
video of Muhammad and zishan where they
tackled the issue of this when it comes
to this new U uh thing that's happened
with the Lev tahar Jewish cult who are
directly they follow I mean they follow
the talmud ETC again we do not come and
say it's every single Jewish for that
matter but what we're saying is brothers
and sisters that why is it then if this
these things happen which is becoming
more predominantly it's happening a lot
uh you know with these cases we we do
not come and say Jewish grooming gang
gangs or Israeli grooming gangs Etc so
we need to be just in this matter as you
can see the propaganda that they uh
pushing out there will be inshallah
combed with the brothers inshah
muhammedan doing excellent work so check
that out keep an eye in and the
arguments that we make here use them to
defend Islam because Islam has nothing
to do with these violent individuals
till next time
[Music]